once upon a time of war was about to
happen battle lines were drawn the
soldiers were in place ready to fight
but a higher power made them stop
something unexpected and delicious a
warm milk soup our story starts here in
the Swiss countryside in Kapil and Albus
where our special peacekeeper dish was
created almost five centuries ago legend
has it actually let's get your gunfire
he's a historian from the University of
Basel and he knows this milk soup so
well he's even written articles about it
the mere super is an elegant a hospital
of in a conflict situation
Winston hunted now in Atlantic in tale
by Italian the católica on styrofoam
instant release and on totally new
person it exists as does the informed on
the scintillation side his forceful
disorders and abiding Italian I not the
King Koopa stunned and understand after
a while the soldiers got tired and
hungry so they put what food they had
together
the Catholics brought the milk and the
Protestants the bread and together they
made the legendary milk soup
[Music]
this halted the battle and a truce was
formed the suit became so iconic it has
a memorial in the battlefield and nearly
500 years later the soup is still
playing peacemaker from tomorrow and
this is Robert whose restaurant has been
serving the staff for many years mankind
is Isabelle him and when Hmong 1812 a
difference and hot items lost an meter
freed live on Duncan Landis councils
freaking super been another he makes the
soup the modern way with milk and bread
of course but also with butter onions
leek creamed vegetable stock and some
salt and pepper wish makers air creme ik
life Casa count like we as a firm do you
realized it hops can so next time you're
upset about something with your neighbor
do as the Swiss do you bring the bread
have them bring the milk and have a bowl
of soup together
[Music]